Subhan Allah. Mike, what are you doing
in Medina? You accepted Ali. You
accepted Islam 5 years ago and now
you're in Medina.
You accepted Islam with us. Did someone
teach you how to do wudoo? Absolutely.
Did they teach you how to pray salah?
Certainly did. You know faty?
Absolutely. Oh my gosh. So since then
you have been praying every time you do
wudoo, every time you pray salah, every
time you recite surah fat, they get all
the rewards. Yes. Ah, it should have
been me who to actually I think I did
teach it teach you be on a kajar machine
if you thought about it. Never thought
of it that way. This project bonuses is
about to change the game of salary. A
lot of people give the water wells
orphans and masid and it's beautiful.
Add this to your list bonuses. You know
why? Cuz every time someone learns how
to pray salah, learn surah fat. The
Quran learns how to do voodoo, you get
the reward. What have we been doing and
where's your donations going to go is a
question you're asking. Number one,
we've got onetoone salah instructors
that teach rebirths and born Muslims
around the world. the Japanese sister
who came to Islam. We are teaching her
how to pray salah via salah instructors
and we are giving her a guided prayer
mat. Number two, we are printing 50,000
guided prayer mass in Italian, German,
French, Spanish, Portuguese, Albanian,
and English. 50,000 that's going to be
distributed to Dao tables, mosque, new
Muslim centers, prisons, even ISIS.
Number three, we've been opening salah
hubs across UK and Europe. And we're
going to Latin America where there will
be active salah workshops that we aiming
in teaching 26,000 people a year via our
Salah hubs. Number four, we've got a
salah app coming that will change and
revolutionize those who want to learn
salah and just want to pray salah. It
has a free kibla finder, free salah
reminder, free way of booking salah,
free way of booking a Quran, free guided
prayer mass that you can order. We send
that all around the world and many
things that are free in there and that
is where your donations are going to be
going to sisters. Go to the link and
donate now. £100 can teach 10 to 30
people to £1,000 will teach 100 to 300
people. £5,000 will teach 500 to 1,500
people. Brothers and sisters, imagine a
khar where every time they pray, every
time they do, every time they recite the
Quran, you get the reward. Ahar that
outlives a water well. Subhan Allah.